VOICE OVER: Why do some animals
live so much longer than others?
And what is it that causes the
variation in the ageing process?
One theory suggests that somatic mutations
— changes that accrue in our bodiesover time,
could be part of the answer.
ALEX CAGAN: So there's you know good reason to
suspect that somatic mutations that are altering
the DNA could be having deleterious effects on
cellular function that could lead to breakdown
and kind of consequences that we see in ageing.
VO: But this theory doesn’t necessarily
align with what we see in the animal kingdom.
For example somatic mutations are known to
cause cancers which can in turn reduce lifespan
— and so it would stand to reason that
larger animals with more cells to mutate —
might have a higher chance of developing cancer
somewhere in their body and thus have lower
lifespans. But in fact the opposite is often true.
With a few notable exceptions, larger animals
often have far lower rates of cancer than smaller
ones - a phenomenon known as Peto’s paradox.
ALEX: Everything we know about
somatic mutations and cancer
we would expect that the more cells
you have the higher your chance of
cancer because you just have more cells where you
could be unlucky and accumulate somatic mutations.
VO: What’s more - some of the longest
lived animals in the world are also the
largest despite having so many cells which
could be deteriorating through mutations.
If somatic mutations are linked to ageing,
then something else must be going on - and
now a team of researchers have delved into
the somatic mutation rates of a range of
mammals for the first time - in the hopes of
finally unraveling some of these mysteries.
VO: Somatic mutations can
be caused by lots of things,
like errors in DNA replication or exposure
to mutagens like ultraviolet radiation.
Despite being very common, their
effects are still not fully understood.
ALEX: The most well-known consequence that's
very well established is cancer, but what's less
well understood and still debated is whether
somatic mutations could be playing other roles
uh crucially for example what is the role of
somatic mutation in ageing? Because we know that
as we age we're accumulating somatic mutations
but kind of the key question in the field is
are these a consequence of
ageing or a cause of ageing.
VO: Alex and his colleagues wanted to measure
the rate these somatic mutations were acquired,
not just in humans, but across as
wide a variety of mammals as possible.
So they set about collecting tissue samples.
ALEX: so we work with a variety of partners
including the London Zoo so ZSL Institute
and the CSIP which is the Cetacean Stranding
Investigation Program who i'd never heard
of before but they're essentially like CSI
for cetaceans or whales and so we work with
partners like that and different zoos to collect
tissue samples opportunistically from when animals
have died from other causes and so we wanted to
get a tissue type that we could compare across
mammals because we know from human studies that
different cell types in the body have different
mutation rates. And so to compare across species
we wanted to pick one cell type and we settled
on intestinal crypts which are these small kind
of crypt-like structures that line the intestine
and so basically by sequencing these intestinal
crypts from 16 different mammalian species
and 56 different individuals and knowing the
age of those animals when they died we could
count and say okay in this harbour porpoise
that's you know x years old there are this
many mutations while in this mouse you know
that's maybe a few months old we count this
many of mutate number of mutations and then
we can figure out the mutation rate across
these different species and see to what extent
they are similar or to what extent they vary.
VO: Their results allowed them to investigate
whether mutation rates can help explain
Peto’s Paradox - the curious observation
that larger animals don’t appear to develop
more cancers despite having more cells to
mutate. And it turns out that – size is
actually a fairly poor predictor
of the rate of somatic mutation.
For instance cows, giraffes and horses
weigh much more than an average human,
but their somatic mutation rates
don’t follow the same pattern.
It’s clear that having more cells doesn’t mean
you have a higher chance of developing cancer,
but the weak correlation between body mass
and somatic mutation rates across species
suggest that lower mutation rates are
not behind this - and that large animals,
like elephants, must have another
trick for lowering their cancer risk.
However, there was one factor
which seemed to correlate strongly
with somatic mutations, a factor that
is very relevant to ageing: lifespan.
ALEX: By far for us the most striking finding
was we found this strong inverse correlation
between lifespan and somatic mutation rate.
VO: For example, the naked mole rat is about
23 thousand times smaller than a giraffe,
but they both live for around 20 to 30 years. And
this new research presents an explanation for such
similar lifespans in such different creatures -
they have nearly identical somatic mutation rates.
ALEX: And so what that tells us is that somatic
mutation rate is evolutionarily constrained,
so there's some reason that evolution
is shaping somatic mutation rate
um to be similar at the end of lifespan across
species and this is consistent with the somatic
mutational theory of ageing that somatic mutations
play a causative role in the ageing process.
VO: Across the animals tested - somatic mutation
rates proved a reliable predictor of lifespan,
and that provides strong evidence
for the theory that somatic mutations
are a cause of ageing, not a result of
it. But the team isn't finished yet,
they want to expand their study as far and
wide across the tree of life as possible.
ALEX: From evolutionary theory and what we're
seeing in mammals species with longer lifespans
seem to have lower mutation rates so if we can
start to understand how species with even longer
lifespans than humans are maintaining their genome
integrity and lowering their mutation rate there's
a potential to kind of learn from the solutions
that nature and evolution have already found
uh to potentially find ways to lower the
somatic mutation rate. You know whether
that will one day be possible I don't know but
in principle if one could lower the somatic
mutation rate that could be a very effective
way to do things like lower cancer risk or
you know slow the ageing process but so
that's you know that's kind of the moonshot
far future thinking of how this kind of
research could potentially be relevant.